ok let's get into audience questions for
this week first one is from Sally hey
David what warning signs do you notice
that someone might be bad with money
okay I've got some macro montt ones and
some micro ones so as a big thing when I
hear that someone is rolling their
existing car loan into their next car
loan because they owe more money than
the car is worth but they really want to
get a new car that's a big red flag
you're paying interest upon interest
you're paying for two cars at once even
though you only have one and that's a
really big red flag to me that someone
might not be that good with their
finances now of course we can all
imagine a situation where you have
someone who has no choice their car has
been has some major repair that's
necessary the cars worth 4 grand they
owe 6 and the repair is 3 grand
does it really make sense to put $3,000
into a $4,000 car so they go and they
trade the car in for 2500 bucks and roll
some of that loan into some new loan in
very specific circumstances I can
understand why that ends up being the
least bad option I'm not talking about
that I have many friends who over the
years particularly in our 20s would say
I'm just sick of this car but I found a
great deal on this one and they're
willing to get me out of my loan and I
say well when you say get you out of the
loan what do you mean by that they say
well they'll pay off the 5 grand that I
owe so oh and how much are you getting
for the trade and they say $3,500 which
basically means you're taking $1,500 in
negative equity and adding it to your
next car loan and that's just going to
compound so that's rarely a good option
and it's a sign to me that people are
not good in terms of personal finance
another one is anytime I ask someone how
much something costs and they tell me
how much it costs per month that's not a
good sign now with something like a car
it's a little bit different because very
often you are to thinking in terms of a
monthly cost but if I ask someone how
much is one of these TVs and they say
it's only 90 bucks a month bad that's a
really really bad sign you should not be
going into debt to pay for a big-screen
TV with a car yes most people are paying
for that monthly there's a strong case
to be made that you should not go into
debt for a car that you should find the
cheapest possible car
if it's $900 or $1,500 and run it into
the ground but when I say how much is
this and someone gives me a monthly
number that's a red flag for me what if
it's only 12 easy payments of a monthly
number that people used to work at
Circuit City and actually later I'm in
the show I'm going to talk about that
and one of the things that was used was
hey you can buy this over 12 months with
no interest and people fell for it
because they said well if it's no
interest then I'm paying the same amount
over 12 months than if I just paid for
it now the difference being that
psychologically you're willing to buy a
much more expensive thing if you know
that you're only making 12 smaller
payments instead of one lump sum so even
without interest it's still a mechanism
that people can get tricked by another
one is when a friend says my credit card
debt is crushing me and then I noticed
that they go to a coffee shop everyday
and they get a $6 frappe a caramel
whatever type of thing and I'm not one
of these latte Millionaire dudes who
talks about if you never bought a coffee
then in 15 years
all that money compounded at 7% would
make you a millionaire that's not what
I'm saying
but if you are spending 6 bucks on an
expensive coffee drink or a coffee and a
croissant every single day but you're
complaining about credit card debt
that's 6 bucks a day should be going
directly to your credit card in order to
not pay interest on that and the same
thing applies for drinks like sometimes
I'll go out with friends and I have a
sense of what people are making from the
jobs that they have in whatever and
sometimes it's the people who I know
aren't making that much money who on a
whim will buy for $15 cocktails and
order two orders of nachos for the table
and walk out of a couple hours watching
a game with $100 bill on a Tuesday night
and those are not smart financial
decisions do you have friends who do
this oh yeah absolutely yeah and it's
not even about fulfillment so much I'm
sure it's not about getting the value
out of what you'd have for that time or
absolutely that you're buying it's just
about looking like a high roller it is
that's pretty dangerous and when you
think about it would you have just as
good of a time having a beer and then
hanging as you would spending a hundred
bucks if you are in a tight financial
situation I think most people would have
an equally good time just having a beer
or two
for four five bucks each and some peace
of mind to go along with absolutely so
yeah those are some red flags to me that
I see and I could go on there's lots of
these but also buying a way more
expensive house or renting a way more
expensive apartment than you need now
sometimes it's a calculated decision
listen my commute
I can walk rather than needing $100 a
month subway pass okay that's $1,200 a
month that you're saving and if you're
deciding to pay a little more and now
you can walk to work there's a health
advantage I get that but sometimes those
those trade-offs just really don't make
sense and that that's another one that I
noticed sometimes